resuelve para z y tenemos 5 z 7 menor
que 27 o menos 3 z menor o igual que 18
así que este problema que nos piden
resolver es un problema de desigualdades
compuestas tenemos dos restricciones
para nuestra zeta
tenemos que encontrar todos los valores
posibles para los cuales alguna de estas
dos condiciones se cumplen o puede ser
que se cumplan ambas al mismo tiempo ok
entonces esencialmente lo que vamos a
hacer es resolver cada una por separado
y después vamos a unir las soluciones es
decir vamos a considerar ambos conjuntos
como una solución global muy bien
entonces lo que tenemos de la primera
desigualdad vamos a ponerle esto es 5 z
más 7 menor que 27 muy bien entonces lo
que podemos hacer de ambos lados de
restar 7 para irnos para ir despejando
nuestra zeta de aquí por supuesto se
cancelan y me quedan 5 z y esto debe ser
menor que 27 menos 7 que son simplemente
muy bien entonces ahora para poder
despejar la seta necesitamos dividir
todo entre 5 de ambos lados y la
desigualdad no cambia debido a que
estamos dividiendo entre un número
positivo si hubiera sido negativo
entonces si se tiene que invertir pero
en este caso no porque 5 es un número
positivo y eso es ya muy bueno que lo
tengamos muy presente así que del lado
izquierdo lo que me va a quedar es z y
del lado derecho me queda 20 entre 5 que
son 4 entonces aquí tenemos nuestra
primera condición que podría cumplir set
vamos a ver qué pasa del otro lado
tenemos menos 3 z es menor o igual que
18 muy bien entonces esto es muy
inmediato porque lo que tenemos que
hacer es dividir entre 30
hay que tener mucho cuidado hay que
tener mucho cuidado porque en este caso
si estamos dividiendo entre un número
negativo así que en este caso como
dividimos entre un número negativo la
desigualdad se invierte y ahora tenemos
mayor o igual muy bien entonces qué es
lo que tenemos menos 3 se está entre
menos 3 simplemente es zeta que es mayor
o igual que 18 entre menos 3 que es
menos 6 menos 6 así que nuestras dos
condiciones las podemos resumir estas
dos en que z es menor que 4 o z es mayor
o igual que menos 6 ok entonces esto es
sumamente sumamente interesante y para
ver qué es lo que está ocurriendo vamos
vamos a ver qué es lo que ocurriría en
la recta real
así que vamos a poner hoy un poquito más
derechita
yo creo que con esto sirve muy bien ahí
tenemos nuestra recta donde se
encuentran colocados todos los números
reales digamos que por aquí anda el 0 el
1 el 2 el 3 y el 4 este es el que sí me
interesa y nos vamos hacia atrás en
menos 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 menos cinco y menos
6 muy bien aquí están los números que ya
dije pues aquí sería por ejemplo menos 7
acabando el 5 en fin entonces nuestro
primer conjunto digamos z menor que 4 z
menor que 4 entonces no vamos a incluir
el 4 vamos a dejar la bolita abierta
pero todo lo que está a la izquierda del
4 si lo vamos a tomar si vamos a tomar
todo lo que está a la izquierda del 4
muy bien este es una parte de mi
conjunto solución
cualquiera que sea menor que 4 es una
solución a este conjunto de
desigualdades porque es un oh y si
satisface al menos una con eso basta
ahora bien del otro lado tenemos que z
debe ser
mayor o igual que menos 6 entonces el
menos 6 lo incluimos y nos tomamos todo
lo que esté a la derecha de menos 6
incluso el 4 verdad el 4 está a la
derecha en menos 6 entonces como puedes
darte cuenta tomamos toda la línea toda
la línea cualquier punto en la línea
real cumple ya sea la primera condición
o la segunda o ambas no por ejemplo qué
pasa con el 0 el 0 está justo en ambas 5
por 0 es 07 claramente sí es menor que
27 y menos 3 por 0 es 0 que claramente
también es 18 entonces pueden satisfacer
un una condición por ejemplo el 4 el 4
va a cumplir que menos 3 por 4 es menos
12 que si es menor o igual que 18 pero
si multiplicamos aquí por 4 de 5 por 4
20 más 727 y no es cierto que 27 sea
menor estricto que 27 es exactamente
igual entonces cómo puedes darte cuenta
hay números que cumplen alguna condición
o puede ser que cumplan ambas lo que sí
es cierto es que toda la recta real
satisface alguna o ambas condiciones